of course not everyone has been able to
go down that path in the four months
that Kovac 19 is upended our lives
physically it's also had a tremendous
impact on us psychologically a poll by
Angus Reed found 31 percent of Canadians
said they feel worn-out and fatigued 28
percent feel anxious 22 percent said
they're worried and only 16 percent said
they feel normal
what is all this stress doing to our
brains
Susan wit Bourne is here with some
insight she's a professor of
psychological and brain sciences at the
University of Massachusetts and she
joins us from just outside Boston hi
there
you know I've heard lots of anecdotes
about people being tired and distracted
and having trouble sleeping but what is
this pandemic actually doing to our
brains and are we wired to cope with a
crisis that has no end in sight this is
the most unusual of stressful events
perhaps ever although of course there
have been previous pandemics and there
have been Wars I mean there's all kinds
of traumatic events people have lived
through this one is different because it
is global it is uncertain in terms of
its ending and it leaves us with really
feeling very depleted in our ability to
cope so is there such a thing as crisis
fatigue or Quarantine fatigue in' and
how does it manifest itself in our
brains in our bodies we've never seen
this kind of fatigue there's something
called compassion fatigue which we're
seeing of course in healthcare workers
and mental health workers as well it's
just a really strong source of burnout
but for the average person Quarantine
fatigue is just something we don't even
know what to do with so the natural
response is to give up and I think what
makes that it makes it harder to keep
the energy going to remain vigilant is
that it seems to be getting better in
places that have been practicing good
public health so people say oh well I
don't need to worry them because the
trend is going down but the trend is
going down
because people are complying and when
they don't the trend spike so there's
that and then there's this distance of
yourself from the actual stressor which
again is somewhat similar to war
terrorism and all of the stressful
events that everybody goes through but
this one it unless it struck you or your
family somebody you work with a neighbor
it doesn't feel quite real and the
stress both fear of the virus and and
financial uncertainty for a lot of
people who have lost their jobs can that
affect your cognitive abilities yes it
can cortisol is the stress hormone and
we know that cortisol is supposed to
show sort of a peak in the morning and
then go down throughout the day peak
again on the next morning but what
stress does is it actually ironically
flattens that curve which is not a good
curve to flatten people who are under
prolonged psychological stress show a
flattening of their diurnal or daily
variations in cortisol and that impairs
their health long-term what are some of
the signs that someone is becoming
overwhelmed huge stress manifests as
nightmares even trembling you know a
very low mood you know great deal of
anxiety and so yeah you can easily see
people being stressed but you can also
see it in terms of denial people use
denial when they're stressed it's a
really natural way to kind of fight off
bad news
so you might see denial and that might
be some of the people who sort of
minimize the whole thing and say oh you
know it's nothing or I've survived or I
don't need to worry about this or why
should I worry about this so you can see
both extremes of people's ways of coping
how about the separation from loved ones
who we'd usually turn to in times of
stress does that make things worse and
are there actual physiological effects
from prolonged social isolation yes
there are and there's been a great deal
of concern
a psychological community especially
with older adults which happens to be my
specialty and social isolation among
older adults is a problem in general but
it is exacerbated by the enforced social
isolations on the plus side though
people are resilient and older people
are resilient they've lived through a
lot so people are finding ways to
overcome the social isolation and I
think being very creative about it well
yeah and people are connecting virtually
like we are you know using FaceTime and
Skype and zoom is that really a
replacement for in-person contact or
does her body and our brain respond
differently to connecting that way the
body definitely responds to touching you
know touch has its own host of benefits
so you're missing out on that no denying
it so there's that but then the fact
that people are going out of their way
to surmount the physical distance then
can also be reassuring to people because
you might be getting calls from people
you otherwise wouldn't and maybe even on
a more regular basis because people are
checking in with you to see how you're
doing do you think there could be a
long-term impact from this pandemic on
the psychological health of people I
definitely do and and it's interesting
you asked the question that way because
one of the things that I study is the
effect of kind of contact social context
history on psychological development so
there will be a pre kovat and a post
Kogan reality but humans are social
animals we want to get back together we
want to overcome this and we're
resilient so we're going to see changes
some of them will be bad but some of
them might surprise us because of the
resilience that people show
[Music]